what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and it looks like d23
coming up in a week now actually looks
like it might be a little bit more
exciting than we already thought it was
going to be which may seem a little bit
weird because it was already pretty
exciting with the anticipation of what
they could possibly announce from marvel
studios at d23 however to add to the
hype even more it looks like we could be
getting a new spider-man movie
announcement at d23 it also seemingly
looks like we do have a confirmation for
nova and to top it all off we might get
a shang chi announcement not only for
possibly a new movie but possibly an
announcement of him appearing in
multiple other projects which seem leo
has hinted at so a lot to discuss in
this video d23 is right around the
corner so let's get started and of
course if you are new to the channel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news now this is
all coming from a poster that disney has
officially released for the upcoming d23
event on this poster is a lot of stuff
and it's not just marvel it is
everything disney and it's pretty much
everything that they're going to talk
about at d23 this is specifically for
this year's d23 now we're not going to
really go in depth on everything in this
poster but you can see many recognizable
things we see the simpsons donut in the
top right tinker bellows at the top to
the right of her is dumbo maleficent
sits in the middle we have one of the
avatar creatures on the left toy stories
buzz lightyear on the left boba fett
ship we have winnie the pooh we have
angel which is the female version of
stitch we have an x-wing on the right
down below we have mulan we have elsa we
see aladdin's lamp on the left we have
grogu baby yoda we also have a dragon
which i believe is from enchanted we
have indiana jones on the bottom right
and a bunch of other characters but
let's talk about specifically of course
the marvel characters but if you're a
big disney fan in general this poster is
really really exciting but specifically
for the marvel fans we have something
very interesting in here and i'm going
to start with it and that is spider-man
in the bottom left he's pretty big
there's a big emphasis on spider-man in
this poster to me it seems like what
this poster emphasizes the biggest is
obviously mickey in the front but then
spider-man on the bottom left indiana
jones on the bottom right and grogu in
the middle left and of course maleficent
in the top she's right in the center and
the top and of course captain america
shield on the top left now like i
mentioned this is kind of a teaser of
what they're going to be talking about
at d23 so it's very very interesting
that we see spider-man on here the
reason it's so interesting is because
spider-man is sony sony has the rights
to spider-man and yes they do work with
marvel studios to get our tom holland
spider-man and the mcu however typically
they don't let disney or marvel studios
really announce big spider-man things
that typically comes from sony however
it looks like sony might have gave them
permission or this is simply comics
spider-man and they can get away with
that since they do have the comic rights
so they could always say that this is
simply comic spider-man and that's why
they put him on the poster however right
now spider-man no way home the more
fun-stuffed version is back in theaters
for some people that is it'll hit
theaters in a lot of different countries
at a lot of different times but for the
majority of people it is back in
theaters now and after spider-man no a
home released in theaters about a week
or two after kevin feige the president
of marvel studios and amy pascal an
executive producer for sony and
spider-man came out and said that they
were already working on spider-man 4.
they said this because they said they
didn't want fans to have to worry about
a sony and disney marvel studios deal
where we could possibly lose spider-man
in the mcu like we had that big scare a
few years ago and that was almost a year
ago it was nine months ago so we could
probably assume they've been working on
something in the meantime since they
stated 9 months ago they had already
begun to work on spider-man 4. now we
can assume that spider-man is going to
be in avengers secret wars so it would
make sense that we would get another
spider-man film before then especially
since right now nobody should know who
peter parker is people do know who
spider-man is but i'm assuming the
avengers are going to want to know who
spider-man actually is who's under the
mask and i think something needs to
happen where people actually start
remembering at least people close to him
that peter parker is spider-man or
spider-man as peter parker people like
mj ned doctor strange wong since he's
the sorcerer supreme right now and
whoever the new avengers are going to be
i think this needs to happen before we
go into secret wars i'm also not sure if
the other spider-man the other peters
toby maguire and andrew garfield i'm not
sure if they actually will remember tom
holland spider-man it's kind of messy
because they are peter parker themselves
so i'm not sure if the spell to make
everybody forget that peter parker as
spider-man works on peter parker even if
it is a different universe peter parker
but regardless if they don't remember
him they're going to have to be four
secret wars because i am hoping and the
rumor has it that they're both going to
show up for the film and it just makes
sense it's a movie that's going to have
a bunch of different variants in it and
i find it really really interesting that
they put spider-man on this poster that
is a teaser for what is to come at d23
especially since we know that a
spider-man movie is in the works right
now so i can think of two things that
could possibly happen with spider-man at
d23 one is that this is indeed about a
new spider-man film in the mcu sony
might have gave permission to disney
after all kevin feige has been working
close with sony for their other
spider-man movies that do not take place
in the mcu so it does seem like they're
getting along pretty great right now so
perhaps sony said sure go ahead announce
something at d23 it's a huge event it's
a great opportunity it works for both
disney and sony that's one of the
possibilities and of course i hope it's
what actually happens but the other
possibility is that this could actually
be about the animated show spider-man
freshman year because if you notice if
you take a look at the spider-man it's
actually not tom holland spider-man it
looks like andrew garfield spider-man
but andrew garfield's spider-man also
looks the most comic accurate so this
could simply be a comic slash animated
spider-man and this could be a tease for
the animated series they told us a lot
about the animated series at sdcc so
perhaps they're kind of done talking
about that in the meantime and hopefully
this is indeed about a movie but we'll
have to wait and see and luckily we only
have about a week left to wait now
another thing to notice in this poster
in the top right is a nova core ship the
star blaster and this is also very
interesting because nova has been
confirmed by some outlets to be coming
to the mcu with his own project so the
fact that we're seeing a nova corps ship
here is kind of interesting because the
last that we heard the entire nova corps
and xandar was completely decimated by
thanos however that actually sets up
nova because if everybody in the nova
corps is destroyed the nova 4 should all
go to the last surviving people and if
that's only one person richard ryder
that's how we could get our nova so
perhaps we're going to get that official
announcement at d23 after all since the
project has been confirmed by
deadline.com also deadline confirmed
that marvel studios is going to be using
the moon knight riders for nova with
these big confirmations it would make
sense that nova is coming very very soon
so i'm guessing that one of those empty
slots in phase 6 is going to be a nova
project and this nova core star blaster
could be teasing us that we are going to
get an announcement for nova at d23 now
this also could be about cosmic rewind
the guardians of the galaxy ride at
disney there is a star blaster ship
there but i'm hoping and my fingers
across that it's going to be for a nova
announcement especially if they truly
are revealing the rest of phase 6 i
believe nova is going to be in there now
let's take a look at a symbol on the
very very bottom left right above the
little mermaid ariel's tail this is the
shanxi logo so this means that they have
intentions on talking about shanghi at
d23 now we know that a shanghi sequel
has been confirmed by marvel studios
we're getting a second xiang chi film
but also at the same time simulio has
hinted several times that he could
possibly be involved in other mcu
projects there's some people guessing
that he could possibly show up in
she-hulk but we also know that he is now
going to be an avenger wang has
recruited him and wang is kind of
showing up in everything right now so
there's a big possibility we could see
simulio not in just one other project
but multiple ones i'm not really sure
right now where marvel studios is at
with the shang chi sequel we know
director dustin daniel [ __ ] who
directed the first shang chi movie is
going to be directing avengers the kang
dynasty so that might mean that the next
shang qi movie is a bit away unless
they're going to go with a different
director which i hope they don't because
i truly loved shang chi and the
direction that dustin daniel [ __ ] took
it but expect some type of a shangqi
announcement whether that's him showing
up in another film or possibly the
sequel announcement and of course i have
to mention the black panther symbol on
the bottom right now we obviously know
that black panther 2 wakanda forever is
the next marvel movie coming out we only
have a couple of months to wait so
there's no surprise here that it's on
there because we know they're going to
talk about wakanda forever and possibly
give us the second trailer for it so a
lot of very very exciting things to look
forward to at disney's d23 it starts
september 9th but the marvel panel is
september 10th just about a week away so
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell because we're going to
be talking about it all weekend please
don't forget to like the video and give
me your thoughts about this poster in
the comments down below for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you